we just put in the second vehicle uh
we're re-blowing up the bubble and we're
preparing to do a comparison test side
by side normally air pollution you can't
really see it you can't really see how
bad it is so we're trying to use this
to demonstrate it visually so we're
gonna be running a bio weapon defense
mode on here uh we have a hepa filter
installed it's gonna show us the
effectiveness of the hepa filter versus
a vehicle that does not have the hepa
filter my weapon defense mode engaged
we're gonna signal smoke
go smoke
going
so the cabin is now pressurized
as the smoke is released
um
so all the air that's coming into the
cabin
is
going through the hepa filter which is
very good at taking out the particles of
smoke
so as you can see
the cabin is
staying nice and clean
even though the outside world is
quite a hostile environment
this filter is
99.97 percent effective
or better
against particles of any size
oh like our particular in the car right
no particulate in the car
no red
the car is clean
immediately you can see a lot of a lot
of dust here on the inlet side of the
filter and then on the back side
over here you see nothing which is good
i'm going to lift this up and we'll see
the carbon filter which is probably also
going to be quite red from capturing all
that smoke
there we go
um then i'll pull this filter off and
we'll see the the real hepa filter which
is also going to have some red on
you it even see it
on the back side of the filter here so
it definitely caught a lot of this dust
and
filtered it out so that it's not getting
into the cabin and into your lungs hepa
stands for high efficiency particulate
air filter the great thing about a hepa
filter is how well it filters out very
very fine particles like pm 2.5 and even
smaller and those are very bad because
they can be small enough that they get
into your lungs and stay in your body
over 4 million people die per year based
upon exposure to bad air quality and the
world health organization says that over
90 of people live in environments that
have bad air quality with wildfires in
california and other extreme climate
events happening worldwide it's really
important to be able to provide clean
air to everybody so that's why we have a
hepa filter in our vehicle
[Music]